c'est un bruit qui fait frémir plus d'un
le bruit d'une de rompre à l'esthétisme
particulier pas trop petit pas trop
grande des courbes tout en rondeur juste
ce qu'il faut pour se faire plaisir et
se pavaner avec style une philosophie de
vie
la vespa rassemblé fait découvrir ce
jour là le patrimoine et les paysages du
nord atlantique première ray casamania
col haut rhin découverte pour les
pilotes d'un produit purement locale la
farine de manioc de sa production à sa
transformation
une partie gourmande qui met tout le
monde d'accord vous l'aurez compris la
vespa c'est le fil rouge l'élément
déclencheur de rencontre de passionnés
quel que soit l'âge et la catégorie
sociale des fanatiques qui sillonnent
l'île du nord au sud en mode dolce vita
[Musique]
aves pas on prend le temps de découvrir
le panorama des routes de bananier en
passant par les champs de canne la
petite en a dans le moteur elle est tout
terrain et surtout passe partout mais
elle peut se montrer aussi très
capricieuse qu'est-ce qui se passe la
table de nuit
il faut que ce soit dans le beau une
grande famille vespa qui se réunit pour
la première fois
weis patate madinina club et vespa club
un choc inter générationnel qui réunit
52 propriétaire de la moto la plus
connue au monde
j'ai 71 ans jean continue ils y allaient
de m'engager qu'on ne connaît pas des
gens qui ne connaît pas qu'il sauvait
après des spas des jeunes de la vespa
mais la vespa c'est quelque chose qui
est un peu plus ancien est donc
aujourd'hui on a invité club avec un peu
plus d'aînés donc aujourd'hui on est
nombreux on est en partage ces multi
générationnelle et voilà c'est fort
sympathique elle s'appelle dolores
toulouse ou encore hippolyte et elles
ont pour objectif en avril prochain de
faire le tour de la guadeloupe à la
rencontre d'une autre moto mythique lac
rona